avanti west coast they've cut their
services so what's what do you what's
your take on this what do you say is
going wrong
this service has been going downhill for
a number of months you ask anybody who
travels regularly on it actually go on
the twitter feed for a banting you'll
you'll see those frustrated comments i'm
afraid it simply isn't government
they're good enough
to hear from a government that's been
out of office all summer where
everything is blame the workers blame
the workers what about them what are
they taking responsibility for this is
about a company which has been allowed
to
fail in its recruitment drive not to get
enough drivers in place not to train
enough drivers and a transport sector
has overseen that but has done
absolutely nothing about it but carries
on paying this company millions and
millions of pounds supposedly to run a
timetable we have a failing company that
has conspired with a failing government
collectively they have they are failing
together to run the railway but it's
this easy mantra now blame the workers
point the finger at the workers he said
it himself that no one has withdrawn
their labour these aren't contracted
hours that they're refusing to work this
is not a strike
so i don't see how the transport
secretary can sit there this morning and
say that this is his responsibility i
asked him to sit down this week with
myself and sadiq talk to us about it
let's work together see if we can bring
the size together see if we can get an
agreement why because this is affecting
literally millions of british passengers
businesses right now we've got plans for
the summer you know we're expecting a
million people in manchester next
weekend we've got manchester pride we've
got city palace we've got
big music events taking place i'm
hearing already particularly from pride
that ticket sales are down because of
this avanti debacle which the government
has overseen
honestly it's just not good enough it's
not good enough for the people out there
whose plans have been thrown into chaos
this summer the transport secretary
should not be just throwing the the
finger of blame at the unions and the
workforce he should be sitting down and
resolving this
okay and he says it's about as left
drivers deciding to stop volunteering
for overtime outside their normal week
that's why he says it's a de facto
strike
well it's a company that's run the
service down as i said has failed to
recruit enough drivers over a number of
months fail to train them and has lost
goodwill they have destroyed the good
will that's there and if you're going to
run the railway on volunteers which is
in their business model and was in the
virgin business model before if you're
going to do that as a company you're
going to have to work hard to keep
people with you and and work with those
those drivers but they've completely
failed
to to do that i sat down with avanti
this week it doesn't seem like the
transport secretary is holding them to
account he's given them a free pass they
can do whatever they like as far as he's
concerned because they're parroting his
mantra about it's all the unions i sat
down with them this week i asked them
why did you not notify a city as big as
ours where they've got so much happening
you just didn't even tell us you were
doing this that is not right and they
had no explanation for why they why they
did that and i also said to them they
must bring back to us a credible plan to
restore the timetable within days or we
will ask the new prime minister to
remove this contract from this from this
company and lastly i said in the interim
they should declassify all services that
are running on the top on the reduced
timetable from today no no first class
if they did that that would release
seats to the booking system so at least
people who are struggling to get to
manchester next weekend would have more
chance of doing so
so you want the ultimate sanction if
this can't be resolved for the contract
to be removed so essentially putting the
service back in government hands it's
you're saying that you think that grant
shaps would do a better job of running
the railway do you
it can't be any worse you know when
you've got passengers scaling fences at
oxen home train station to get out when
you have mass cancellations on monday
you ask the passengers here who use this
service it can't be it can't be worse uh
and at least perhaps you'd have the
ability then to take the ticket prices
down which are outrageously expensive at
the moment people who have bookings to
travel on trains in august are being
told oh no those are not valid anymore
we've unilaterally said they're not and
if you want to have a seat well you
might have to pay more to go in standard
premium i mean this is the service that
they are running and this is what the
transport secretary is over overseeing
and it's just not good enough this
summer for the government to sit back do
nothing go on holiday and say blame the
workers blame the workers the ordinary
people who they were clapping last year
and now they're pointing the finger of
blame at them saying it's all their
fault well it's not all of their fault
this is a management failure this is a
government failure they should be
sitting down today and sorting this out
and if the transport secretary picks up
the phone to me says right come down to
london if you can get there and let's
sit round the table so i would go
because it's that important to our
economy as i said a million visitors
coming to manchester next week but it
might not be that high because of the
damage that's being that's being done
our economy is trying to recover from
kovid our bars our restaurants our taxis
and this government is hitting them
again by their incompetence and their
inaction on this issue we are paying as
taxpayers for this timetable service
between london and manchester okay it is
not being delivered the government
should hold this company to account get
them to do what they're being paid to do
and that's the transport secretary's job
okay and this is happening in your city
of course are you saying that you
personally are powerless then
no i sat well
i asked the transport secretary to meet
with me and there is a role i'm prepared
to play with the trade unions that's
where i can help and that's why i wrote
to him with sadiq khan last week we were
prepared to play our part it's too
important to us there's nothing about
politics here this morning i am speaking
up for my city for my city region for
the businesses who are losing out but
for those who are having their plans
disrupted because they can't get to see
family i heard a friend last night
saying that 30 wedding guests can't get
to his daughter's wedding because of
this it's that important it's people's
lives it's people's businesses i am
ready to play my part in getting this
timetable back to where it should be as
quickly as possible three trains an hour
that's what the country's second city
needs with the country's capital city
why is the transport secretary playing
politics i'm not prepared to actually
put people first
i want to ask you about the strike
action that's been going on yesterday
there was a national strike there's
another one tomorrow there's a strike
here from on underground workers from
underground workers in london
what do you make of labour's a policy on
this at the moment kierstarma says he
doesn't want party members on picket
lines do you back that has he got the
right call there
well every i would say every labour
politician has to make their their call
on this and mine is you should support
people who are fighting to protect their
income in a cost of living crisis how
can how can we not uh do uh do that you
know these are serious at times uh
people are really struggling i'm hearing
reports of people having to turn off
every electrical appliance in their
house already because they just simply
can't afford uh to make things add up
you know these are really serious times
where everyone has to do what they think
is
is right and i would say
the latest party should
okay andy burn i'm so sorry i'm going to
have to cut across you because we're
just about to fall off air i do
apologize thanks so much for your time
this morning we appreciate you talking
to us thank you